mi piacerebbe parlarvi oggi di un genio
di giuseppe porzio
mi sarebbe piaciuto parlarvi di giuseppe
porzio che cosa avrebbe fatto in questo
momento mi sarebbe piaciuto parlare di
della sua prematura scomparsa e del
dolore di un gruppo di amici e parenti
mi sarebbe piaciuto parlare di come un
gruppo di amici e parenti abbia
canalizzato questo dolore abbia fondato
un'associazione in suo nome che porta il
suo nickname
mi sarebbe piaciuto insegnerà a scrivere
sis crack perché quando parlo sbagliano
tutti ma vorrei parlare anche del the
fab lab in suo nome che si basa sulle
sue idee sulla sua volontà sul suo modo
di fare a grassano uno sperduto comune
alla provincia di matera invece oggi vi
parlo di una storia all'interno del fab
lab vi parlo di una storia e di un
progetto magari un'idea ce l'avete già
era una giornata di novembre come tante
quando uno dei soci sis crack che vive a
pisa e che cracca il sistema insieme a
noi si impegna per cambiare le cose ci
segnala un interessantissimo progetto si
tratta di un violino open source
acustico e stampabile in 3d in buona
parte stampabile in 3d attraverso le più
comuni adesso sempre più diffuse nelle
nelle nostre case stampanti 3d fdm
inutile dire che appena informati di
questo progetto abbiamo cominciato ad
analizzare il sito alla ricerca di
informazioni visitando la sezione make
dedicata al do it yourself perché l'open
source è proprio questo se qualcosa
non hai le capacità non è le risorse per
comprarlo mai le capacità per costruirlo
puoi farlo da solo o come è successo nel
mio caso farle insieme alla tua
community
immediatamente è scattata la molla e
cercando all'interno del sito abbiamo
analizzato quelli che sono i componenti
del del violino di getto iniziamo a
stampare i primi telecom bisogno di
pezzi per costruirlo di 4 pezzi tre non
sono stati stampati quasi per miracolo
tutta d'un fiato e e chi sta un ben tre
di sa cosa vuol dire stampa rompe alla
preoccupazione che venga bene le notti
insonni rinunciare alla propria vita
sociale insomma vuol dire tanto
incredibilmente i primi tre vengono
fuori senza problemi poi ci accorgiamo
di un problema
uno dei pezzi il manico non riesce non è
troppo grande non entra all'interno
della nostra della nostra era di stampa
come è consigliato sul sito in un modo e
nell'altro dobbiamo trovare una
soluzione qualcosa avremmo inventato a
un certo punto era brillante idea in
siamo realmente aggiornare a ragionare
in tre dimensioni
potevamo siro ovviamente era impossibile
stamparlo considerando che un'area di
stampa tutte le stampanti 3d open source
e auto costruite come le nostre
all'interno del nostro laboratorio è di
circa 20 centimetri per lato su tre assi
xvi y e z
ma cominciamo a ragionare che
posizionandoli in diagonale
nel volume di stampa quindi
posizionandolo verso l'altro lungo
l'asse z il manico incredibilmente
generava ovviamente per chi stampa in 3d
mi capirà che posizionare un manico in
quel modo è una follia vuol dire
aumentare esponenzialmente le ore di
stampo aumentare i rischi perché
purtroppo mentre roe di stampa vuol dire
stare se ancora più collante che il
pezzo venga bene magari basta un black
out tutto va in malora ecco invece noi
noi ci siamo arresi abbiamo deciso di
voler veramente teletrasportare come è
successo in star trek
come facevano doc e marty da un capo
all'altro del mondo un violino dall
america a grassano proprio chiedete pure
ma allora perché sei tu a parlarne qui
oggi di certo con vini concederò una
performance non ha ancora imparato a
suonare un violino
oppure vi racconterò proprio di questo
come è stato possibile tele trasportarlo
insomma dopo appena 33 ore di stampa e
come dico io questo non lo dicono i mass
media ma la vita è troppo breve per
stampare in 3d il manico è venuto fuori
insomma avevamo tutti i pezzi
ovviamente l'entusiasmo era tanto ma
eravamo lucidi al momento abbiamo solo
dei pezzi serve mettere l'insieme non è
ancora un violino ragazzi manteniamo la
calma
iniziamo così a cercare di capire i
pezzi mancanti le corde le meccaniche
adattare gli ultimi componenti di fatto
un po pesantuccio sto facendo anche
fatica a tenerlo in mano perché due dei
componenti le anime che lo tengono
insieme il progetto originale dei
ragazzi che l'hanno fondato e di o basse
metto beckett rinnova e prevedevano in
carbonio
purtroppo quando si parla di glocalità
c'era giornate in modo globale connessi
con il mondo ma poi agire in locale
saranno pure i conti con la realtà no in
pollici quali misure da una ferramenta
non le trova il carbonio te lo scordi
quindi abbiamo cominciato ad utilizzare
l'alluminio quindi insieme tutti quanti
e provare a montarlo non solo ci fu un
caso abbastanza curioso ci rivolgiamo
per le meccaniche le corde ovviamente
ignari ignoranti in materia di
costruzione di strumenti musicali ad un
professionista della zona lui ovviamente
entusiasta alla nel vederlo e si
complimentò con noi per l'audacia con
quest anno portando avanti questo
obiettivo però forte della sua
esperienza maturata in costosissimi
corsi da liutaio ci disse ciao nì
ragazzi però bello bello tutto ma un
vostro violino il vostro valean non
suonerà purtroppo l'avevamo scoperto un
po e generano documentati stavamo
studiando come costruire gli strumenti
musicali vogliamo capire come suona uno
strumento e avevo capito che purtroppo
la cassa di risonanza del nostro valean
è composta da tre pezzi mentre la regola
la tradizione la lunga tradizione dei
maestri liutai di violino vuole che deve
essere un corpo unico come giusto che
sia
noi questo ripeto l'avevamo l'avevamo
scoperto ma ormai non ci tiravamo
indietro se avevamo visto un video in
cui oval in suonava beh quelle buono con
le cattive doveva farlo pure con noi
e inutile dirvi che ce l'abbiamo fatta
era bellissimo medico era perché il
primo modello che è stato veramente un
miracolo nessuno addirittura meglio di
questo è purtroppo è andato un po
distrutto nei lunghi viaggi
però era bellissimo sembra un violino
vero non so come siamo riusciti con una
certa fortuna anche a ricreare delle
venature si millenni eravamo increduli
inoltre tra stampati in pla materiale
plastico sì ma ricavato dal mais una
cosa che non si era mai vista
contentissimi e insomma il nostro valean
incredibilmente suonava come potete in
parte sentire su questo violino e non so
la sua storia mi è sembrata molto simile
a quella dei calabroni no che la
struttura del calabrone in rapporto al
peso non gli permette di volare ma il
calabro e non lo sai quindi vola ma
dalle il nostro palin non sa che la sua
cassa di risonanza e compassata tre
pezzi e quindi suona quello che è voluto
raccontare attraverso questa storia
all'interno del nostro umile laboratorio
e che nessuno deve dirvi cosa è
possibile che cosa impossibile e che se
oggi possono qui a parlarvi di un
violino e tutto grazie all'open source
al voler pensare condiviso perciò voi
siate makers sia the hacker's siete
malati del fai da te siate tutto ciò che
volete l'importante che sapete imparare
dagli altri e non solo se abbate
imparare dagli altri con gli altri per
costruire insieme un futuro migliore vi
lascio con una citazione di peps e vi
dico che noi abbiamo semplicemente
provato a guardare la realtà da un'altra
prospettiva da un altro punto di vista
ea superare i nostri limiti come c come
ci ha insegnato peps me mi chiedo se noi
a grassano siamo riusciti a
teletrasportare dall'america un violino
a portarlo qui oggi a matera che cosa è
possibile fare in qualsiasi altro angolo
del mondo
grazie
[Applauso]